[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back take
your seats please
so that we can continue with our keynote
session it is my great pleasure to
welcome today morning here business
leaders from across Europe from north
south central Eastern Europe with great
stories to tell our first speaker will
be Maximo Ybarra CEO of kpn followed by
franco basu nini chairman of open fiber
Alison Kirby president and CEO of the
TDC group Martin vladchik who's an
investment director at PPF and as the
chairman of the Supervisory Board of
Teton and last but not least Gervais
policier who is orange group deputy CEO
as well as the chairman of orange Spain
with that I would like to invite Maximo
to make his opening presentation yeah
thanks very much welcome welcome to to
everyone to EA to the Netherlands I'm
now becoming more and more Dutch for
quite a long time in in the Netherlands
I will start with a with a very I mean
easy chart and this is about how this
market is you know that very well
because you have been listening to our
Minister Molokai sir this is a country
where throughputs
spits when it comes to access is
particularly developed the average 4G
trooper is 42 megabit in the country
which is quite high compared to our
European countries and and when it comes
to fixed broadband 98% of the population
is already 100 megabit of course it's a
very regulated market recently there has
been an additional regulation on cable
there is infrastructural competition
lots of regulation I also have to say
that 10 years ago our fiber fiber in kpn
was less regulated than what it is right
now so 10 years ago there was less
regulation than today it's of course a
very competitive market there has been
some developments recently the merger of
tele2 and t-mobile in the Netherlands
but it remains very competitive as you
can see in 2018 in the first three
quarters of the year Europe has been
slightly growing 0.3 percent even - is
practically nothing but in the
Netherlands that performance has not
been particularly active it was minus 2
percent recently we introduced all
stakeholders and financial markets our
plan our strategy this strategy is very
simple the foundations are just three
three pillars three main pillars the
number one is about building the
infrastructure so we are an operator we
work in a telecom space so we decided to
accelerate all the investments in
infrastructure is of course not only
mobile but it's in particular
fiber-to-the-home kpn has been the
pioneer in the fiber-to-the-home journey
in 2008 when we had the joint venture
with Reigate fiber and that is something
that now we are enhancing we are just
accelerating because we believe that
that is the way forward there is no any
other way forward as role and explained
in the keynote speech at the opening
keynote speech if we have the right
infrastructure then the logical
consequence is point number two and
point number two is that we really
believe in convergence customers are
currently looking for it they don't call
it convergence because it's quite a
weird word but what they want it just
say one-stop shopping experience which
means that they want to have their
Abidin fixed it's a seamless experience
and they recognize that this ultra
broadband can come from two sides but in
the end it's just the same network is
the weight customers perceive that and
one-stop shopping does not mean only
connectivity but it means at the same
time media TV ultra definition TV and
more and more connected homes so the
concept of connecting homes is now
finally becoming one of the most
important things that customers are
recognizing very important for their
development in the digital society and
the third one is just how can we improve
our operational business model to make
sure that everything will happen at the
right pace with the right speed without
wasting any time so we are just
simplifying the operational model we are
digitizing everything that we can
digitize our they can infrastructure IT
platforms all touch points with
customers who are becoming more and more
digital and that will of course give the
possibility to kpn to make sure that the
infrastructure will be rolled out and
developed in the right timing and
customers will enjoy converging services
these are just a few numbers of the plan
of course you need to put these numbers
in the context of the Netherlands there
are 17 million customers approximately
7.8 million households so the plan again
is building the infrastructure
fiber-to-the-home so we are going to add
more than 1 million new households
connected with fibre with optical fiber
by 2020 and this is not just the end is
the beginning because we are going to
add 1 million by 2021 to the current 2.3
million but then of course the plan is
just going beyond of course we set up
this plan up to 2021 in particular for
the financial markets but our ambition
is to go more more than that much more
than that and and again in the keynote
opening speech I think that Rana was
particularly effective in explaining why
these two networks are or have to work
like in in in in total consistency with
each other he's not only about the fix
and he's not only about the mobile
Mobile is not replacing fixed fixed
wireless is just something that you can
play in specific areas but it's just a
combination of the two the negative
infrastructure very strong and that's
why we are also going into a full
modernization of the network as many
other players and that modernization of
the network is important because that
has to be 5g ready then of course in
terms of regulations in
of government efforts we have to make
sure the spectrum is going to be
available in the Netherlands for all the
different bad winds as soon as possible
and again moving to all IP this is not
just only like a claim but this is
reality it's moving is the npsbn into IP
connections so that migration has to
happen again in a very short time from
now on fibre
we're also here I mean sometimes we have
been using - coal fiber everything that
is not fiber in reality so the fiber to
the corner fibre to the curve that is
not real fiber it's just stretching
copper to an extent that you can get
tactically the right kind of experience
today but if we are just moving forward
and we look at the next five 17 years
that doesn't make any sense we need just
to migrate into fiber to the home and
it's not only about the one gigabit as
we already mentioned earlier this
morning but it's about getting up to ten
gigabit and fiber to the home is already
demonstrated it's a much more efficient
technology compared to any other
technology so if we really want to move
forward as a company it is not only
business wise but it's also in terms of
the society the role that we are playing
in the society and how all different
stakeholders and parties can play this
game to make sure that finally we are
going to have a lot of growth coming
from fiber development yeah
pawn G pawn technologies is is going to
offer this possibility so superior
technology as I mentioned 10 gigabit
again the one gigabit is really the
starting point but the development is
much farther than this a lower total
cost of ownership
I mean efficiency enabling on a man
activation at at the same time lower
energy usage so sustainability is also
an important target when it comes to
fiber to the home rollout and by 2021
where we expect is that yeah more than
forty five or approximately forty five
percent of the houses in the Netherlands
will enjoy fibre to the home experience
and at least 75 percent of households
will have more than 22 hundred megabit
so we are just really working in order
to improve the whole footprint to make
sure that connectivity is not going to
be any issue and there's not gonna be
any answer for customers
that is the way we represent the
Netherlands just try to figure this out
is like by 2021
of course the large cities are going to
be connected fiber tune hum what does it
mean it means that in dense urban areas
we need to have that technology in place
otherwise all these dreams on what you
can do in terms of connectivity are not
going to happen again is a combination
between 5g and fiber to the home that
will enhance enable all these new
applications that will come soon in the
rest of the country as we cannot I mean
roll out everything 100% because also we
have to look at the Roche the return on
capital spending sure but also we have
to look at all the investments that we
are going to make in the future it's
going to be a combination of
technologies maybe in some areas it
makes sense to keep and stretch it a bit
our fiber to the corner but also in some
other areas in rural areas where there
is not the right density then we can
play with some fixed wireless
substitution in this moment we are just
deploying in some rural areas in the
Netherlands hybrid technologies which is
the VDSL plus forging tomorrow will be d
d SL + 5 g or fiber-to-the-home
depending on the different demand that
we can collect in different areas we
also see that in some rural areas
customers are willing to pay more to get
the state-of-the-art future-proof
technology what can we do all together
again it is not only an objective of a
company of course we are just business
leaders running companies that have to
be profitable in the future
because we need to guarantee the right
return to shareholders but at the same
time we have a duty when it comes to
society and we cannot play this game if
we are just simply alone or we have only
like announcements that everything is
going to be simplified we really need to
walk into work hand in hand to make sure
that everything will happen at exactly
the same pace that customers are
expecting they are not waiting for
something happening all of a sudden
they're just really willing to have that
kind of experience right now so what can
we do what local governments what the
government can do again on top of the
kind of predictable regulation framework
in the future so we need to understand
in the next five years seven years as we
are going to deploy a lot investments in
this market really huge amount of money
is going to be invested in to roll out
the fiber what do we really expect from
regulations are we going to get some
additional like nil a breaking news that
are going to these rap a little bit our
plans yes or not so we need to have that
predictable framework but on top of that
there are some other few things that can
be done effectively here you can just
read some of them we need to allow the
sweet face out of legacy infrastructure
so the moment we just switch off copper
what are the costs related to switching
off copper
how can we lower costs when it comes to
permits and fees that I mean is the best
way to allow us to make sure that our
investment can have the right return and
also again the pace and the speed of
execution of our infrastructure allowed
surely times for approval of
construction licenses you know that more
than 70% of the total cost that we have
on rolling out and connecting homes is
just because of a construction we have
to make sure that okay when we get a
license for construction that that
happens in a relatively short time
one-stop shop for procedures just only
one procedure not many so then in that
case we have the chance to really work
on the right framework and make
procedures uniform is the Armani session
of legislation every everywhere in the
country has to be the same and I think
at every single state member the
European Union should work exactly the
same kind of direction 5g and
fiber-to-the-home will really make
companies that are operating this Center
infrastructural company is really at the
center of the ecosystem there will be a
lot of economic growth so this is an
undisputed concept is really common
sense if we really want these countries
European Union of our European Union to
keep growing we need to be the
infrastructure without it we are not
going to get anywhere households I mean
customers are not explained
in complicated stuff but they're just
following what I mean is is really
happening I'm not talking about virtual
reality or augmented reality this will
happen by the way so smart working
experience is going to definitely change
but I'm talking about ultra broadband TV
definition I'm talking about connected
homes security all these new devices
stuff and services are coming up in
order just to fit up and to increase and
improve the conversion proposition and
then of course in the cities and people
so how can we make sure that smart
cities are just not only like an
advertisement claim but becomes reality
and the gigabit infrastructure can
really attract businesses again our plan
is not only building just for households
and and and for businesses it's really
about people and I always like saying
that the moment we roll out fiber I
would love to have all the households
business parks powered by kpn so we had
I've had the chance to really have like
a I don't know I played in each single
house in this country that says powered
by kpn it means that we will be really
helping customers to be part an active
part of this gigabit society again just
of my final remark our objective our
mission our vision and our real ambition
is to make sure that we can really build
the digital highways of the Netherlands
and there is no any other alternative
option we are going to do that and we
are going to do that with help and
support of all stakeholders government
local governments and to make this like
a very successful journey thanks very
much
[Applause]
thank you very much Maximo um as you
mentioned I think in the future indeed
new technologies will need fiber
absolutely everywhere and I wonder
whether there's a particular kind of
stretch strategy or can have thought
leadership within KPN as regards how
you're preparing for a converged future
and also if you have any expectations
with regard how convergence will
actually impact on demand and how demand
will evolve in a converged world yeah
definitely I think this is the the most
relevant question because in the end we
are just building all everything that we
are building with the only purpose to
make sure that customers get a benefit
and intangible benefit is a material
benefit so this why when when we decided
to go quite straight forward into the
convergent proposition what we
immediately thought is that yea
convergence is not only putting together
mobile and fixed because it's something
that customers already take for granted
they are just spreading it and they know
very well that the troop would latency
and capacity will improve over time so
they just want to make sure that there
we are on a very reliable infrastructure
they're just not waiting for or maybe
yes no they want to make sure that they
are only reliable infrastructure having
said that what we are now planning is
just look how can we enhance our
proposition and and the first point of
that is is the famous IO T's connected
homes
I just hate saying I or T's because that
doesn't mean anything but Condit and
Hounds means something more is like the
robot cars are becoming connected cars
and on that front there are many things
that we can do most of the things are
nice to have in this moment but are
becoming in some parts of the population
of mass who have I mean we are talking
about security cameras yeah we are
talking also about how can we make sure
that customer can enjoy seamlessly the
opportunity to benefit from over the
tops just in a very easy way
plug-and-play how can we make sure that
there is no hardware when it comes to
modems Wi-Fi routers
because it's already on the cloud how
can we also play with new services there
are more as I mentioned earlier in terms
of the virtual reality augmented reality
that there are propositions that of
course are now coming up but our real
intention is to make sure that
everything that we launched in the
market is going to be material the
customers can can really touch it and
they can keep like improving their
package by the way feeling very
satisfied because they are on a very
reliable infrastructure so that's our
whole intention last but not least is
the user experience everything we do it
can be very complex but if we don't have
plug-and-play as I said one-stop
shopping if we don't have the right user
interface right interoperability with
the applications now that we all have
these applications we tend to have many
of them rather than having just only one
if you really can manage all your
services with just very intuitive user
interface that will be absolutely super
Winnick great thank you very much we
will return to these crucial issues and
the discussion later on now let me just
advise franco Pasolini to deliver his
opening remarks thank you it's a bit
this morning I doubt late on my PC the
program of the 2010 ftth council
conference held in lisbon the comparison
with the program of our today's
conference is impressive starting with
the participants in the keynote session
in lisbon the largest operator in the
panel was portugal telecom while the
others represented potentials usual
users the focus was still on convincing
the participant of the benefits of
deploying fiber-to-the-home in less than
10 years as we know the
telecommunication landscape has
dramatically changed as for the
infrastructure sector in comparison with
2010 I see three main evolutions first
there is no longer a need to argue in
favor of deploying fibre to the home
nobody challenges that investing in
fiber networks
is a crucial need for growth and jobs
and for the European competitiveness in
the global economy digital
transformation artificial intelligence
Internet of Things smart cities and so
on
require fiber today the question is no
longer if but when
today many national policies do not
focus only on fiber to the home but
include fiber to the cabinet but in the
new code the European Union is now
indicated optical fiber as the point of
reference for very high capacity
networks the younger Commission is
promoting very high capacity networks by
its debate society objectives and
several member states governments are
doing the same second in 2010 further to
their own deployment was still a very
early stage except in few countries like
Portugal and Lithuania today
fabula to the home deployment has become
mainstream thirdly since 2010 the most
remarkable the development is the
emergence of words early operators the
words an early model has attracted new
players all over the you know in the
United the European Union last year the
European Union as a knowledge formerly
the benefits of the woods and only
business model and the fact that it is
better placed to attract long-term
investments in the new infrastructures
the newer European code has suggested
and authorized the National regulatory
authorities to provide a lighter
regulatory regime in favour of words
early operators even when these
operators enjoy significant in market
power
let us now imagine our successor in 2025
looking back at the program of this
conference let us the screen distinguish
between what we can already predict and
what will depend on fire
census contestants which cannot yet be
anticipated let us start with
certainties first the implementation by
the national governments and regulators
of European electronic communication
code will provide for a positive
regulatory framework for the development
of fiber-to-the-home networks in Europe
important our meanwhile the guidelines
that the barrage is to issue in the
coming months over a number of aspects
of the utmost relevance for the market
starting from the definition of very
high capacity networks like a very well
the devil is in the details
bearish will have to provide a common
identification of the network
termination point and of the first
concentration and distribution points a
common approach to the co-investment to
geographical service of network
deployment second 5g will boost the
deployment of ftth networks operators
who deploy fibre to the home are able to
deploy dense fiber networks also for 5g
at marginal cost already in 2016 the
European Commission highlighted the
interplay between fiber and wireless
deployment requirements and call for
coordination between the actors as for
investment in cellular base station and
fiber infrastructure recent researches
show that the synergies between the ftth
and mobile 5g networks can be very
significant it can lead to huge savings
in capex especially if if these
synergies are considered from the
beginning in the construction of
greenfield infrastructural projects
third the water only model will further
gain traction there are different
reasons to believe this first of all as
a Wilson only operator is not an active
on the retail market it has no conflict
of interest with activities of the
moreover normally we'll sell all the
operators do do not have copper legacy
networks and only focus on the
deployment of new fiber-to-the-home
infrastructures which are less costly to
manage in addition building
fiber-to-the-home infrastructure
requires considerable time and medium
long term investments we'll sell only
operators are better placed to mobilise
investors specialize in the asset class
of greenfield infrastructural projects
were attracted by lower risk and I'd be
modeling if you look ahead the model
will benefit from another important
evolution of the market in the next
years players active on the telecom
market will multiply and diversify
producer and distributors of
audio-visual products such as sky o TTS
such as Facebook Google Amazon energy
gas and water distribution companies
insurance companies it is highly
probable that these new players will
prefer dealing with water only operators
allow more flexibility for the service
the new players intend to provide and
guarantee fairer competition among all
players involvement than vertical
integrated operators
let's now finally move to the
uncertainties the first factor of
uncertainty is whether regulators will
succeed in fostering the switch off of
copper networks and the consequent
migration to FTE age networks agreed
medium-term timetables for the switch
off region by region would definitely
accelerate the development of a tth
network however while in some countries
like speck like in Spain the encampments
themselves have decided to focus on FTTH
in other countries reliance on the
existing copper networks is still seen
as a medium term strategy for deployment
for the deployment of very high capacity
nation
these operators are betting on
technological developments such as
g.fast vectoring and so on that boost
the connectivity of fiber to the cabinet
networks but the adoption of these
technologies it's not easily compatible
compatible with the need to ensure full
equivalence of input among all the
service providers as requested by
several and erase and in any case even
in the best case scenario G faster and
vectoring can only represent short-term
solution which will not be able to
satisfy the more demanding connectivity
needs of the gigabit society
the second question mark related to the
market support will consumers subscribe
to FTTH networks which provide better
services and that thus more expensive
than copper connection in several
countries demand could be weak due to
adverse marketing practices on the side
of some incumbents such as anti
competitive pricing policies and
misleading advertisement as national
governments did to promote the take-up
of digital terrestrial television they
will have to develop schemes to support
the migration of end users to FTTH
networks such as vouchers to families
and SMEs
the third question mark related to the
digital policy objectives that will be
set by the future European Commission
has mentioned setting the G debate
society's objective is contributed to
render ftth deployment mainstream will
the next commission for sure this policy
will the next Commission follow the
trend of the leading countries and set
the 10 gigabits as the next objective
finally the first question related to
the usage of economies of scope and
scale parallel deployment of
th and 5g networks accepting better than
city areas is not the most effective way
to spend scarce resources the FT TGA
council europe study on the convergence
between fixed and mobile networks shows
that converging both networks in order
to have a single infrastructure capable
of offering all possible services both
in fixin and left mobile level is not
only the most economical rational option
but also the only one that allows us to
enjoy the benefits of countless new
services as soon as possible
but with operators reach agreements for
joint deployment and other network
sharing formulas we regulators accept
operators managing their networks into a
single network company to conclude a
broader reflection begins to take shape
and is already developing in some
countries such as the US and Italy the
global technological competition which
is in progress is also played on the
ground of telecommunication
infrastructures several countries China
above all have strongly accelerated
relate the realization of future-proof
infrastructure ftth flg edge cloud
computing throw the location of huge
amounts of public resources and the
power to strongly coordinate the
investment of private actors how can the
Western countries face this competitive
challenge is the infrastructural
competition among private operators the
most suitable model to compete are the
virtues of the free competition among
private players enough to compensate for
the lack of coordination then effective
duplication of investments and the
natural short-term vision of private
investors reluctant to finance long term
greenfield projects or should the state
promote or incentivize the consolidation
of a telecommunication infrastructures
or even the development of a single
double-sided network ftth foggy capable
of mobilizing the long-term public and
private investments needed to accelerate
the deployment of the latest generation
network throughout the country
guaranteeing absolute equality of
treatment to all service providers
according to the world sale only model
or at least could this this be the best
solution
for market failure areas in order to
quickly reach universal coverage of the
FTTH and 5g double-faced network the
pros and cons of the two solution
infrastructural competition versus a
single will sell all infrastructure must
be careful wagon I do not have an answer
but the question is now on the table
thank you for your attention thank you
very much Franco let me ask you about a
quite heatedly debated question related
to it to the Italian market so there is
quite a lot of discussion about and
speculation whether or not telecom
italia and open fiber might be merging
is there something that you as the
chairman of open fiber would actually
expect to happen anytime soon sorry
there is quite a bit of speculation in
the Italian market about a potential
merger between Telecom Italia and open
fire as you know it's about the the
current Italian government but also the
previous explicitly declared the
intention to favor a sort of riemann
apologize ation of the plc ultra
broadband network through a merger
between the network of the
former incumbent Telecom Italia and the
new fiber network of of open fiber in a
single Network held and managed by a non
vertically integrated operator according
to the world cell only models this is
the intention the Parliament has
established recently that the merger
could be favored by some incentives
decided by the National regulatory or
sole authority at the condition that
this will be in II in word said only
operators such move would reduce the
risk of inefficient application of
investment in most dense areas and no
investment at all in less dense and
rural areas a single operator served in
the world market very tellus could have
all the incentives necessary to extend
coverage and guarantee a geographically
average access price favoring the
development of a strong competition
among service providers but it is clear
however that the project could only be
carried out with the consent of the
shareholders of the two companies
concerned or at least of the majority
and so the issue is now on the subject
of a lively discussion among the
shareholders of the incumbent Telecom
Italia and among the shareholders of
open fiber the outcome is not addictive
the alternative could be the heavily in
a single wholesale only company only of
the assets useful for the full
deployment of the ftth infrastructure
and the memory of the 5g backbone with
agreements assuring a gradual migration
from the ibrid to the fiber networks
what I can exclude is a consideration as
a consolidation of the different
networks within the encampment which
would in my opinion faced insurmountable
obstacles
in the light of the italian the european
competition laws thank you very much
undoubtedly the discussion will continue
may i just move on to allison Kirkby
allison would you like to make your
opening statement please no I'm fine
thank you thank you as a bet and thank
you for the invitation to be here today
hopefully you can see me above this tall
podium I have recently transitioned from
CEO of a challenger mobile operator to
see your of an incumbent which is a
significant market player across all
technologies actually except for fiber
so I have to wonder whether some fiber
companies are on the same path from
challenger to market leader and in fact
I actually feel that we had a challenger
in fiber in Denmark today and I'm sure
you'll be able to shed some light on
some of the dynamics that's going on in
Denmark during this conference it's
certainly a very interesting time to be
in this industry and I'd like to some of
the issues that we have faced and are
now addressing at TDC group in Denmark
first some context TDC was acquired just
under a year ago by a consortium of
investors the majority shareholder is
the international infrastructure
investor McCrory infrastructure and real
assets along with three leading Danish
pension funds which are also major
infrastructure investors in their own
right we are still in the process of
finalizing our strategies and our
organizational setup but we are very
much accelerating towards food network
separation already this summer and
accelerating our investments into fibre
in fact yesterday we announced the name
of our op Co our new digital service
provider which will be called new day
but let's go back to fiber as fast
stable and secure Internet connectivity
is an integral part of our daily lives
digital infrastructure has become as
important to society's
as water electricity and heating and to
future-proof european digitalization and
connectivity we strongly believe that
wide-scale fiber deployment will be
required many incumbents today to have
chosen to upgrade existing networks as
it has been difficult to attract the
capital for digital infrastructure
investments with time horizons for
returns of 15 plus years this has also
been the case for TDC which was very
much a cable television LED tail go
telco and had recently upgraded its coax
network to deliver gigabit connectivity
thereby prolonging the life cycle of his
existing networks integrated telcos have
traditionally been perceived as risky
investments and given the fierce
competition a heavily regulated market
and very much checks on mergers and
consolidations investors have started to
look elsewhere for better returns and
rightly so based on the recent returns
that the sector has delivered here in
Europe as pension funds and private
equity funds and investors in general
have faced a challenging environment to
achieve the growth from their
investments in recent years they have
started and particularly pension funds
they've sought o you typically stout
sectors to secure long term steady
returns and are taking direct
investments just as we've seen in
Denmark and since fiber investment
requires a notoriously long term
perspective the utility light
perspective is reflected in fiber
operated as well and this is adding to
the mutual attraction furthermore we're
seeing a significant government demand
and consumer demand for high-speed
broadband connectivity in Denmark which
we believe will only accelerate I
believe and my owners believe that these
developments together are a forceful
driver for fibre investment and fibre
rule out
raus Europe and it's these factors
combined that are the reason why TDC has
now fully embraced a fiber strategy even
if it does look a little bit late in
some areas which brings me to separation
and the wholesale only model integrated
telcos have often had to navigate
complexities as a result of containing
two essentially very different
businesses a broad and diverse range of
employees and very disparate risk
profiles the retail side of the business
is increasingly competing and sometimes
converging with platform service
providers that move fast and break
things and a competitive response
requires investment into digitalization
and incredible speed and agility the
average age of our OpCo or as we know
call it new day is actually about the
age of 30 across our six and a half
thousand employees the infrastructure
side of the business requires a
long-term investment horizon and the
ability to streamline operations
minimize costs and deliver steady
progress over a very long haul and
recognize there is delivering critical
national infrastructure for our
governments and the average age of our
Necco team is around 50 so very very
different businesses to increase our
ability to do these things
simultaneously and succeed at both our
owners have decided to separate into a
wholesale only and a customer-focused
entity or as I'm saying Neku and no new
day as we have called them so far by
doing so each entity can focus with
laser-like precision on their core
capabilities and ambition for the future
with the appropriate business mindset
and the appropriate time and investment
horizon embodied into both Brown echo
it's easier to meet the sea
sniffing increase in demand and maximize
fiber deployment by quickly scaling up
our fiber rule-out ramping up fiber
production digging and mobilizing
investments for the long run we can now
do this in an uncompromising way without
the quarterly expectations from our
shareholders and the markets in general
in order to subsequently offer open and
carrier neutral wholesale access and get
maximum utilization from our
infrastructure with a sound long-term
return from the investment so with the
separation investment takes on both the
risk profile and the return requirements
tied to infrastructure this is very much
the business strategy in line with our
owner consortiums focus on
infrastructure investment the same logic
applies to our op co new day up cause
focus is to deliver the best customer
experience via our offerings and our
services technological evolution has
made it much easier to develop relevant
and agile solutions for our customers
through customized and on-demand digital
services and our new op core has a role
to play in aggregating all of the
services that enable a digital life for
individuals households and enterprises
across Denmark and their purpose is to
purely focus on making sense of
Technology in a digital way speed and
innovation is essential for the consumer
facing market and our auto organization
has to work with speed in this shorter
time horizon so that we can separate the
OpCo benefits and really focus on bolder
and more risk-taking at digital style
investments this very much falls in line
with a train towards transition from
linear to on demand TV consumption which
our separation will position us
perfectly for we are also enabling
consumer choice where our customers can
compile their own a la carte lineup of
TV channels and on-demand services such
as Netflix and HBO Nordic through our
content packages and they can mix and
match it by the month or by the week
depending on what which is the latest
show that they want to watch the
separation logic ties in neatly to pull
us to preferences from policymakers
regulators and customers all of which
call for competition at the service
level and our new streaming product that
now has Premier League footballs I will
be able to watch Man United when I'm in
Copenhagen we will serve we will sell
that streaming product to all service
providers in the country they don't need
to be a UC customer to get it going
forward we fundamentally believe that
going forward the logics of investment
in infrastructure with long term secure
returns and the need for faster riskier
bets on consumer facing markets will
drive other telcos towards separating
their operations these are two different
vehicles with different risk profiles
from an from an investment point of view
for TDC mixing the DNA of an integrated
telecom doesn't make sense for us going
forward and we are truly excited about
the future prospects for both parts of
our company these developments are
revolving around a relevant backdrop of
broader technological and sectoral
trends the telecom sector will be
engaged in two major races over the next
decades fiber rule out and delivering on
5g networks to races that are linked
from a telecom operator perspective I
see fiber and Phi G networks as
supplementary not complimentary 5g
connectivity will be a wireless additive
to fiber networks but fiber forms the
backbone as an enabler for 5g hence 5g
rollout is likely to be a strong driver
for fiber demand
investment perhaps in the long run the
very long run five j5g may become a
substitute for fiber deployment but only
in some areas our task in the
foreseeable future will be to get fiber
as close to as many households as
possible and in some areas 5g may act as
virtual fiber or air vibrant for the
last mile but other technologies can
serve the last mile as well so we need
to keep an open mind toward this well I
haven't seen much analysis of is the
question of whether we should expect
overlapping 5g networks or the option of
nationwide consolidation leading to one
wholesale only 5g network as a shared
resource and co-investment opportunity
if we take the case of Denmark does it
really make economic sense to develop
three national five gene networks for
five and a half million people or will
the industry and policy makers opt for a
single shared network maybe it will make
sense for macro sites but does it also
make sense for the micro sites one thing
we know for sure is that 5g networks
will be demanding to build and expensive
and for the immediate future we should
not expect 5g coverage nationwide so in
summary the demand for high-speed access
is on the rise for governments and
consumers and enterprises and incumbent
telcos like ourselves have no option but
to invest in the next generation
technologies of fiber and 5 G for us at
TDC having owners with a longer term
investment horizon and a belief that
utility style returns will be possible
over the long term is encouraging us to
accelerate separation of our network so
we can wholesale high-speed technologies
to all and separately build a
customer-focused
aggregator of digital service provisions
for the future so it is no mean feat I'm
glad I'm doing it in Denmark because
it's a lot smaller than many other
markets
my colleagues run but we are truly
excited about the potential that we are
creating for Denmark as a country but
also for our employees and our owners
going forward thank you thank you very
much Alison and congratulations to
launch a new day it's obviously a very
very exciting period for you I look at
this with this development of separation
went quite some curiosity there has been
quite a lot of skepticism about
separation of network and services and
also even more broadly wholesaling and
that work over the last few years and
now there seems to be a trend towards
separation towards wholesale only
operator is emerging so I wonder why do
you think suddenly this is becoming so
attractive for investors and then why
now well I think there there is a deep
frustration in the public markets about
the returns that they have been able to
get from their investment than telecoms
over a number of years and that's been
driven by regulation and whatever else
but in a very very competitive market
but you know we have to continue to
invest in the infrastructure that
supports digital lives and that
infrastructure is costly and at the same
time you've got new forms of capital
increasingly coming from infrastructure
funds pension funds that just have a
very very long term horizon and are
starting to view the telecoms
infrastructure as a potential utility of
the future and and they see that as an
opportunity
and we as a company we meet that
investment you know TDC was going down a
route of choosing to invest in content
our shareholders clearly didn't like
that option and they voted with their
feet but TDC was very it was very
cornered because it couldn't aver invest
with this current ownership at that time
in both fiber and content and
digitalization and give the returns that
the market expected so the new owners
with that very long term horizon gives
us a new access to capital but we
recognize it will only make sense for
them if we open up that infrastructure
to all and turn it into a wholesale
model and and because we have as a
company over the last few years
heavily invested in digitalization and
we have a phenomenal position in
entertainment we can now separate this
service led company there is truly
differentiating at the service level and
really focus on what it's good at so
that's why it makes sense for us but I
think this this demand for returns this
demand to invest and this new form of
increasingly large amounts of capital
with a different investment horizon
allure return on capital is what I think
is driving this latest round thank you I
will move on to martin martin you have
actually led a company through the
separation process so we were very
interested and hearing from you about
your experiences and key learnings
good day as i was asked in january - you
sure about share with you the separation
story of certain what we did with an
incumbent in the czech republic it will
be slightly aside from the main topic of
this conference FTTH rollouts
but i think
the separation helped us to response
three very critical questions for ftth
roll out how to finance it how to
effectively roll it out and how to and
this is the most important how to
monetize the thing at the end of the day
because everything in this world is
about the return on the investments so I
try to take you now in the five minutes
through the separation story and I will
pick up or focus on points where where I
think we the separation helped the
process and the evolvement of first
capital investments as Allison said is a
utility is a telco utility in new kind
of utility can will be treated like this
and help definitely the infrared co
company which is called setting helps to
make clear vision and perspective how to
build and how to develop the telco
infrastructure but for the beginning
where I come from is the private equity
fund PPF which is central european based
investment funds they're our size this
is the size the numbers what you see
this is 2017 numbers it's present mainly
in Europe but a lot of operations in
Asia now and the u.s. diverse in
activities the biggest one is finance
financial services banking finance
consumer finance second biggest
telecommunication and from the
telecommunication you will be a novice
speak about one one country which is
Czech Republic but there are mobile
operators in five other countries we
acquired from telefónica in the year
2014 Czech Republic and Slovakia and
last year in Prague
are aware of the acquisition of central
and southeastern European assets from
Tallinn or these are this is the stripe
through through Europe I'm sure you've
heard at least the name or maybe the the
basic frameworks of this which basically
brought us this is this is already a
live model which Alison will now with
the team and TDC run through the show
and they have to set it up but this is
this is how we set it up in in 2050 and
we operate it for four years I will go
from the bottom the setting is the infra
part of the company so we moved all the
assets into almost of the all of the
assets have assets physical assets into
the set in part the lower part there is
a new brand it's completely separated
from everything
it has own corporate bodies processes
business plan P&L its operating on the
wholesale market so the operators are
our customers
unlike the o2 which is the the OpCo
which is based on the relations b2b and
b2c customers and it's taking taking
care of all the supporting systems there
is a part of mobile core and what is
important there is an spectrum although
spectrum remains with o2 why did this
happen in in private equity if we will
if you know it or if I take you in the
into the kitchen of private equity you
always have to find a value creation
story if you want to succeed in this
world and in this business and we based
the value creation on T hypothesis first
we we noticed difference
between let's say treatment and
evaluating of utilities like yes
electricity water compared to compared
to the telco which is also very capex
heavy industry and there was a big gap a
big difference between between these in
in the multiples between evaluation of
the energy utility and the integrated
telecom operators so then we said can we
by doing Kinetico can we be treated as a
utility and increase the the value and
the financial financial evaluation of
the company second there was relatively
low utilization in an integrated
operator from the third parties third
parties did not really use the
infrastructure so then we said if we
separate and we make it neutral and just
pure Jose player do we increase it is
the utilization be bigger in this case
you have always to have let's say safe
and certain back and the back back up
here was the shareholder PPF and its
family fund there is a one physical
person behind that which behaved very
pragmatic and is taken as pragmatic and
very value oriented and there is as
there is a one person it's also very
quick short decision times quick in
decisions and you can move with the
things quite fast forward the DNA of PPF
says something about thinking outside of
the box so PPF did not this case
particular did not afraid to go into the
into the situation or into the make step
into the world when no one before us did
it and my personal belief is what helped
us or make it make the life easier in
this case was that we did not have a
history in in PPF history in telco
industry there were three goals to be to
be taken as an advantage and
achievements through the separation this
is what also TDC RLS and I mentioned
here utility and net go by nature is
very different in let's say the logic of
thinking building up a business plan the
horizon is dramatically different to
unlike unlike the OpCo and let's say
their retail retail b2b b2c customers
where the horizon is much much shorter
and they they live let's say in much
shorter cycles year cycles yearly cycles
so this is this is what brought us to
this situation where we said if we
concentrate and we let the people
concentrate on just the core business
means utility and b2b b2c business this
will very probably help us and help the
companies and will bring result and
better and better better profitability
we were quite sure that if we streamline
and we were separate we get or the OpCo
get advantage in the regulation which
really did because most of the
regulation remains with the with the net
Co and we were quite sure that financing
possibilities private equity world and
fund will will have dramatically
different perspectives if we were
separate and this really this
happens thereafter here I would like to
share with you how it seems to be
relatively it's nice to listen the
separation but it's also nice to to see
that as the first look on the management
board if you if you look on this this is
basically this is basically the network
just it's fully by purpose just a it's
it's very structured there is a clear
cut in the company so this was the first
look when we when we decided in 2014
that we go deeper into into the idea but
then come let's say we came back and we
faced the real situations and the real
systems and now it's see it started to
be much more complicated and let's say
he was said the devil was in the detail
and the devil meant that you have to
touch all the assets and say left all
right
you have to touch all the people and say
left all right you have to touch all the
relations and let's say processes and
say at least how do we do we go on in
the process or we will we will end it up
and there will be some
intercommunication between the two
parties so it started to be much more
complicated and then IT came which is
after 25 years of being integrated
operator this probably will be
everywhere same it there was a nightmare
because you had very complicated things
so we we knew we were pioneers in in
that there were no good examples to copy
and we had we suffered all the
consequence
you
it wasn't just about the IT it was above
the whole complexity of the company we
what we had to do is to convinced
ourselves convince people explained to
the people stayed the goals properly and
then believe that there is a way and we
were sometimes in this situation like
Indiana Jones was on the on the bridge
if there was a bridge or not in it
how did it happen four years from
separation almost four years today
appeared no critical problems in in that
in the in the operation OpCo and natkho
are more in the core business I was on
the part of natkho have to say that we
threw out we were forced throughout the
four years to really clear out and make
clear out all the burdens all the all
the problems and make very vital and
clear strategy strategy towards or in
the for the future there is on both
sides there are much bigger teams
setting was plus 30 percent people so we
run the show with much higher number of
colleagues because we found we need them
either to to sell the products to sell
ourselves all to build and take care of
take proper care of of the infra because
for us the infra was was let's say the
the gold our daily bread what we live
from and we created the value in it so
we made successfully the arbitrage on on
the utility pricing if if you go from
the o2 -1 still equals o to the logic of
this graph says
value before that this is the first o2
value before before separation aid and
of 2014 which is capital market
capitalization we took out setting out
of that year after year something after
separation the values was still there in
the original original 2.7 billion years
and there was certain sides and it was
that was the the the value creation so
this is this is the story how we
separate it how we created the value and
how we open at the end of the day the
way to the first three points what I
what I mentioned about ftth how to make
it how to finance that because there is
a room for financing definitely and we
more easily finance it if we are
separated or then let's go company how
to sell it because we have opened up
ourselves and we have neutral new we are
neutral position hotel operator and then
also how to build it effectively but
this is something what is connected and
we will probably discuss it further more
here thank you
thank you very much Martin it's a it's a
truly exciting story and a very
successful one there is something that
I'm really curious about though you have
been a pioneer with regard to network
separation and then investing in an
originally incumbent operator and then
you moved on and you basically shopped
in central Eastern Europe and you bought
a very very different portfolio asset
lights mobile only vertically integrated
operators across the central Eastern
European region from from Tallinn or so
I wonder how this latest shopping spree
is fitting in with the logics and a
concept of the original kind of a
certain approach and also how do you see
these very different companies sort of
gel into in a way unified group a telco
group which you are PPF is effectively
building let's say acquisition and
shopping or acquisition of Tallinn or
what is what is important in private
equity PPF entered this five years ago
there was no history I say there was
very limited in knowledge in that I
think three critical factors happened or
met and
was possible to make Telenor acquisition
first the success story of separation
there was proved the value creation
concept second we PPF we acquired
critical level of let's say knowledge
and comfort in the industry and we
believe this is this is a good industry
with good perspectives and some
challenges for sure and third we like
the asset so it might be different story
or it will be by nature it will be
different story then then setting but
this is asset for creativity as well so
this is basically basically the answer
thank you very much
moving towards more Western European
group of companies may ask use your way
to make your own statement thank you
it's a long session so when listening to
my to my colleagues system I need the
words of John my father's house has many
rooms we are all faithful of fiber but
if I look at the models developed by the
five of us I see it's quite it's quite
different net co-op Co no separation
wholesale with retail and a machining
when I listened to all this is that all
are successful in one way but what's
important in value for fiber development
first and for technology driven this is
clearly long term commitment for capital
this I agree and this has been one of
the issues for those who have started
fiber first like us in orange we started
the first fiber deployment and of 2006
in Slovakia then we started with France
in 2007 we stopped for one year because
the regulator told us we were too early
compared to competition and we had to
wait for our competitors and to define
the regulation by the way from is that's
a big issue with digital compared to
other utilities that we if we just wait
for competition for regulation
to run for the digital progress and
success we will be always late in this
continent that's at least by my view so
we should start and then we regulate if
there is a need to regulate like the US
or to assistance and like China instead
of just putting the brakes before the
vehicle has started to run so long term
commitment in capital a long term
commitment in technology and this is why
by the way we are always a little
puzzled by this separation of people
between and evens scales between the
medical part and the of core part I see
you have to be very careful that the net
car company are not too far from the
real customers and that they still
continue to invest in technology skills
we just provided at the last Mobile
World Congress demonstration on a
commercial fiber line of 50g gigabit per
seconds in front of the king who is
responsible for that in the teams is
that the net Co teams or the service
chips big question mark so we have to be
careful and I think even if the rest
separation there should be bridges
between the two teams and between the
teams because they will and which each
other you will not define the network of
the future if you don't have a view on
the service of your future and vice
versa
so at least the Ceasar of you in orange
we need to keep both really being able
to enrich each other whatever the
separation third for me commitments this
is a commitment vis-a-vis the
development of the infrastructure in the
country we are operating in 31 country
as a retail operator eight countries in
Europe and every country has a different
model and by the way when I listen to
the word incumbents they are increment
who have been successful also in common
not so successful and if I look at our
group there are two countries were just
being mobile only we are far ahead of
the incumbents
Slovakia this is Slovakia this is
romania and moldova so an other
countries was in comment remains
incumbent able to manage what he has to
manage for the future maybe just a
certified I think there is and one of
the issue for us in Europe or question
mark I sincerely success in deployment
of technology when there is a strong
political will and at the same time
private interest ready to invest with
this political will but so as a
political weight doesn't mean that there
is public money put into the investment
that's another topic that there shall be
a strong political will and for us this
leads me now to the Spanish case I'm
also see I'm the chairman of around
Spain while Spain has been attractive to
us for me by the way we shall never
forget that even if Spain is Latin the
greatest king of Spain Charles the great
was speaking more Dutch plan Spanish
everybody forgets it but we what's great
is this country that it is a liberal
system from me the regulator in Spain is
for is the one behaving the most like
the u.s. to a certain extent and what
has happened with fiber the country has
decided that fiber was important then as
left sink a man run first to build fiber
not imposing any immediate regulation on
the incumbent but then as pushed others
especially orange and Vodafone to say ok
guys if you want to take the race you
can and also creating the overall
climate to have urban planning
regulation which is adapted to the
Telecom Italia telecom regulation this
is what Maxima mentioned to have also
the permits that are in line with was a
telco regulation laws and then to have
an overall teach the country where there
was a race to build infrastructure
with some competition there's been
sometimes duplication of infrastructure
but at a relatively low price and at the
end it does put Spain in the situation
where it is today where we are not far
from 80% of ohm pass today in Spain and
ourselves we are covering today in home
passed a 16 million household in Spain
and we have three million ftth customers
which is our biggest country with ftth
customers first before France where we
have 2.6 million FTTH customers today so
for me the overall climate in Spain has
been very positive and now what's the
situation
you have been FTTH Network in Spain
which some time is competing some time
is partnering we have signed agreements
with our three competitors we share
infrastructure with Telefonica
we share infrastructure with Vodafone we
share infrastructure with mass mobile
and this works quite well today for the
sake of the customers and when we looked
at the retail market situation the churn
is between 18 and 22 percent which means
on fiber which means that there is
complete freedom of choice of the
customer of the supplier so all this has
created for us a very positive armament
regarding fiber we also believe that
it's important outside of Europe we have
started to deploy fiber in several
African capitals which suspension
Casablanca documents on where we have
now about 150,000 FTTH customers in
Africa it looks small compared to Europe
but we shall never forget that we we are
building fibre in countries where the
average of you is between 3 and 5 euro
on mobile so the ability of people to
pay for it is does a big but we think
that for the large cities in Africa
fiber-to-the-home is also
a very valuable solution for for the
future so I will not say more as an
introduction but just to say that
everybody has his own model but at the
end what's important is how quickly we
develop and deploy those infrastructure
and we can help this continent to catch
up with this technology thank you very
much sherry I do have a question I do
have a question to you as a as a major
fiber deployer really leading the race
and France but but also very badly in in
Spain how do you see the role of fiber
in the possibilities with fiber to
actually combat the digital divide which
was which was mentioned by the state
secretary saying that that's also an
objective a political objective here in
the Netherlands but but that is a much
bigger challenge in countries like
France for example and and also what
measures could be taken in order to
prevent from the outset the emergence of
a new fiber divide if you like the
situation is has been treated very
differently in Spain and in France in
Spain this is thanks to competition but
also by letting telefónica had so when
telephony has invested in some rural
areas
the wholesale price and for those who
want to be to compete against them of
the retailers you have to to take the
bitstream offer and so this is in my
view a fair return given to the one who
has built the infrastructure in our
buildings infrastructure in rural areas
in France you know and for Israel many
people in the room knowing that the
country has been divided in three parts
one are the dense areas about 20% of the
French population
we're in fact the competition is a full
competition except for the vertical wire
so for vertical wire we have to co
invest with others the one who is
building the vertical wire in a building
as to open is if a structure to others
then there is a second part which has
the semi dense areas about 40% of the
population where in fact he has been a
kind of friction put by the central
government
on the table to ask to people are you
ready to cover this part of this part of
the country in at the end orange has
chosen to cover 70% of this territory
whereas our competitors are chosen 30%
mainly SFR by the way and there is also
a possibility of co-investment but which
is also the co-investment takes care of
who is investing first with the kind of
increased price for investment if you
invest once the market has started and
from is that's very good because at
least there is a premium given to the
one was the same if to take the risks to
cover the area with fiber you are not so
sure that you question I will come by
the way if I take our fiber network it
falls we are today at 12% usage for own
customers and we add another 10% on all
sales so which means that we have 20%
fulfilling of the network with the
customers and then there is the rest
small towns rural areas where the
regions have organized a concession
system so this is in the hand of the
regions this is called resumed
initiative village in a kind of TPA
where in fact there is a farmer there is
a company that will build and operate
the network on a wholesale basis and
then retail companies will come and buy
trenches so this is milesg
open fiber system of Vitelli which is
applied in sausages but region by region
and with different operators we have I
have met some of our competitors or
partners in the room operating on that
and the system I would say is working
well or less well because in fact
reaction is also linked depending on the
regions there is a kind of pricing but
there is also coverage obligations there
are many things and some regions have
managed e12 other regions I've not been
so good in to managing there are
directions let's say that way now based
on that the expectation of the French
government is to our let's say 80 85 %
household coverage in terms of fiber by
the end of 2020 - so this answers to the
usually read because we believe by the
way when we started - to deploy fiber I
remember the most of the requests of the
local authorities were for schools
universities small business browsers and
for consumers let's not forget that
digital devices so so many linked with
how much we are able to maintain jobs or
create jobs in rural or semi-rural areas
rather than just the consumer IC
consumer can handle with relatively
lower speed but if you want to smart to
start a small business let's say in the
middle of Normandy or Brittany or
burgundy if you have high speed very
high speeds and it will change
completely the game thank you very much
I think we have covered a lot of ground
I would absolutely love to continue the
discussion but I'm afraid that we are
quite short in time but I would really
encourage you to continue the speakers
over lunch and later during the breaks
as well as the audience to think about
all these issues that were covered in
today's panel and I would like to thank
you for the tremendously interesting
contributions
[Applause]